not the return home they wanted after
being expelled from neighboring
Equatorial Guinea these cameroonian
migrants are being repatriated to their
country they've come back broke
empty-handed and scarred by the violence
at the hands of security forces ahead of
Equatorial Guinea's presidential
legislative and local elections
thousands of migrants in the isolated
and oil-rich Central African nation are
being rounded up by security forces and
forcibly deported authorities accuse
them of committing crimes and creating
instability
nonsense says this cameroonian migrant
she says they were there to do jobs
locals don't want working as mechanics
housekeepers or teachers
some were beaten others held days
without food all have had their homes
and belongings seized by the state
fled the violence of Boko Haram fighters
in Cameroon thinking she and her
children were safe she worked as a maid
for years last week she was arrested
separated from her children and all of
her savings were taken away
I was forced to spend three days
cloistered in the house without eating
or drinking Two Soldiers arrested me and
took me to the stadium
they took me to the basement I resisted
but then they forced me to undress and
they abused me
Human Rights Watch accused Security
forces of rape torture and arbitrary
detention
after 43 years in power 80 year old
president Twitter obiang and guemma is
running for re-election he's sure to win
his party the Democratic party of
Equatorial Guinea won almost a hundred
percent of the votes during last
parliamentary elections everything is
normal people feel like it's fun it
doesn't feel like a campaign like in
other countries where there are problems
no everything is normal here both for
the Democratic party of Equatorial
Guinea and for the opposition parties
but critics say it's anything but normal
describing the country as a dictatorship
there is no real opposition they say a
small Elite enjoys lavish Lifestyles
from oil revenues While most people live
on less than two dollars a day the
President says the country's poverty and
problems are the fault of foreigners and
migrants some thirty thousand most from
Central African countries are expected
to be deported before the end of the
year Nicholas Hawk Al Jazeera